[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen und murat halo
effekt gekommen
ihr seht zueinander kulisse wir sitzen
draußen das heißt heute wird wieder
gegrillt
heute gibt es einen morath wunschlos sap
denn er hat also wisst ihr wasser ließ
erlebt alles und ärztlich gewünscht
einen ich hab's nicht die wünsche
betreuen
fotos geträumt hatte nach den
eingebungen musste unbedingt ein broker
dann soll die tories also musste ich
alle meine pläne umschmeißen heute eine
frische burger zu bereiten
und hier ist er ein fußgänger in einem
see mit brötchen als er kenne diese
typischen sesamkringel auf der
türkischen bäckerei hier einen mitbürger
einen petit mittleren peperoni alles
müssen wir alles ist irgendwie hartkäse
sowas lese joghurts müssen also alles
was typisch türkisch ist bei uns zu
hause zumindest und den bereiten wir
heute zu formieren verbesserte soße den
bereiten wir heute zu los gehts aber
zuerst einmal mit dem sager band die
musik gibt's zu den zubereiten denn da
brauche ich im backofen das wird also
fort - und ich freue mich mal die
zutaten für den teig brauche ich einen
würfel hefe 200 milliliter lauwarmes
wasser 30 gramm zucker 30 vom seehof 320
gramm joghurt 260 gramm flüssige butter
vier teelöffel salz und ein kilo mehl
und bei den joghurt nehme ich jetzt
keinem zehnprozentigen junge firmen
einen 35 prozentigen joghurt seid
einfach ein bisschen der für die zeit
wenn mit 10% werde kein konsens zu
finden aber das wenige deckung später
einfach weil ich werde erstmal der
hefeteig hergestellt das heißt ich löste
im wasser aus und berührte dann auch mit
luca und dem traum ist ihr und trauben
sehr grob in seiner türkischen küche
wirklich ein muss das kriegt man auch
als kind immer weil man einfach sagen
mit drin steckt
[Musik]
jetzt finde ich die harte mischung in
einer schüssel pakete den tag über mit
der küchenmaschine aber ihr könnt
natürlich mit der hand erklären
da kommt jetzt in joghurt mit rein und
einfach auch die restlichen zutaten und
an welchem tag ihres zehn minuten zu
einem geschmeidigen teig verkneten
jetzt erhebt teig fertig und er erzählt
ist schön geworden ist fertig meine
arbeitsplatte ein bisschen cool sind
raus formen zu einer kugel und dann darf
der teig in der schüssel abgedeckt für
etwa eine stunde aussehen werden der
hilft jetzt noch auf den muss ich
natürlich die zeit um zum beispiel die
berger pc zu stellen und das ist ein zu
teurer wird habe ich jetzt hier auch mit
zwei zutaten und zwar zurück und rindern
agnes muss den leuten erklären warum das
so ist das zu machen weil ich hab mich
gefragt warum warum machst du mich
einfach gut und einfach die zu dieser
reise genau murat wollte eigentlich
nicht 100 prozentig nehme durch den
fleischwolf jagr zur performance und
dann weiterverarbeitet
ich muss dazu sagen das kann man machen
aber dann hast du einfach 150 gramm foto
burger ich meine du magst du genau aber
es hat auch gewisse anderes wort heilung
zu einem sehr sehr hohen fettanteil also
weit auf mehr als fünf prozent und wäre
ja mal zurück angebraten habt also das
historische knobloch wer es noch nicht
wusste die geht natürlich beim braten
immer ein bisschen ein effekt tritt aus
sondern wird der partie auf ganz klein
das heißt ich möchte es jetzt mit rinder
nacken eins zu eins somit habe ich jetzt
1,4 kilo zurück und 1,4 kilo rinder
nacken
warum diese große menge denn wir werden
heute unsere baustellen helfer natürlich
auch damit dass genau dieser baustelle
freue mich schon drauf und ich muss dazu
sagen das tut das habe ich jetzt
verwendet das steht jetzt ein buch als
geschenk und war haben wir jetzt auf der
messe in wels bekommen und wir hatten
uns eingefroren also jetzt nicht denken
ist abgelaufen
ja das ist eigentlich fahren und endlich
auch unsere lieblingsfotos marke
moobicent genau und zwar die marke
blieben 90 prozent der türken leben in
asien wo die anderen präsenten einfach
vegetarier
jahreswagen wird also das fleisch habe
ich hier schon eine große stücke
geschnitten ist hab ich gleich durch
worden
und dann flog es ganz wichtig dass ihr
das vorher einfach die haut offen rom
wegnehmen dieses ganze noch mit es gibt
so viele leute kaufen sich das und essen
im haus mit die haut gehen
und genau das muss weg und dann wird
auch in grobe stücke geschnitten und
dann kommt beide schlecht ins fleisch
war bislang einfach ein haus kann ich
auch aber schon schwieriger dann
verschwunden weil so kann sich dann die
stücke nehmen
du bist du fotoexperte das heißt hilfst
du mir mal die dinge auf die party oder
fricka wahnsinn
mir war ganz wichtig dass und 15
vogel jetzt die fertige masse aus und
die muss es gut durchgeknetet werden
damit das fleisch und verbinden mit den
händen machen
allerdings trügen dann eure hände
wahrscheinlich eine woche lang das
geschickt
deswegen macht wird mit einem flachen
oder ihr lasst einfach dem antreten
die fertige maßnahmen dessen bisheriger
also kurzak fleisch mit dem ich wieder
meine form
ihr könnt aber natürlich auch vertiefen
den händen formen oder mit einem
ausstecher zum beispiel könnt ihr auch
immer einen anderen burger videos sehen
da die mavs kritiker ist werde ich
hierzu frischhaltefolie einfach
dazwischen legen und jetzt etwa 150
gramm der masse nehmen und hinein
drücken
dann nochmal eine frischhaltefolie
obendrauf solche abbiegen lieber weil es
das sowieso nicht mehr rein sie sind
etwa 150 gramm
aber wenn ich jetzt denkt hat die firma
nicht klappt dann würde ich natürlich
die bands 150 gramm abgeben wenn jetzt
einfach schön drücken den überschüssigen
pfunden hinten drin und dann kommt das
ganze hier ein backpapier menschen
ich wollte eigentlich heute noch einen
bisher machen aber nicht einfach so
penetrant nach futter irgendwer ich
kenne also knoblauch markt und
ungewissheit
klar also ich werde jetzt hier fertig
vorbereiten dann frage ich sie für eine
stunde ein so dass sie sich einfach viel
besser geht und die zwischenzeit muss
sich dann um die verwandtschaft zu
machen
[Musik]
so wie der verteidigung aus und soll ich
jetzt erstmal einen teil heraus denn das
werde jetzt etwas 23 bis 24 burger band
die portionierte zu 80 gramm kugeln
[Musik]
und die habe ich jetzt zu kugeln und
schleifen dann schön das heißt so
zwischen den handflächen und ganz
ausführlich können wir das auch in
meinem verband sehen zusätzlich vätern
auf eine patrouille und drückt sie ganz
leicht sachen
die berger bank werden die prächtige
rambla bei uns also ähnlich wie mit
dieser typischen sesam trainers und
deswegen leitung wird noch vor dem
aufgeben bestrichen und zwar mit einer
mischung aus trauben sirup und wasser
ich hatte zwei äpfel trauben 400
milliliter wasser und ein ergibt die
zutaten verrühren
[Musik]
und jetzt könnt ihr die burger band
damit bestreichen und mit sesam
bestreuen
oder wenn sie vollkommen mit wlan
bedecken volt sowie ein richtiger
schritt
dann nehmen wir die jetzt taucht sicher
ein ganz vorsichtig und dann im seebad
wenn wir das nicht hat wenn man es nicht
hat könnte auch zum beispiel einen
zuckerrübensirup nehmen den türkischen
reich wird man dass nahrung nicht
wegschmeißen und alles weiß auch im
deutschen ja aber auf das hausrecht
macht man einfach gesagt und zwar für
jeden krümel auch bewahren wenn es
bleibt alles reichtum und wenn man
minister wegschmeißt dann bedeuten dass
man halt nicht rechnet ok ich dachte er
weiß mit hunger hat sicher auch ein
grund mal so einfach nichts wegschmeißen
sogar ein kleines lesern kommt zu
beachten
[Musik]
wie bei der bahn ständig ist abdecken
und dann für etwa 15 minuten aufgehen
lassen
[Musik]
nach der aufgezeigt werden jetzt die
brötchen gebacken ich hab hier übrigens
auch ein paar gemacht mit schwarzkümmel
und laser vermischt haben hat mir so
gefühlvoll und trotzdem kaufen und diese
komme jetzt in den vorgeheizten backofen
bei 190 grad ober unterhitze etwa
künstlern minuten und danach leiten sie
sofort mit verlassene mutter bestritten
was kümmert mich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die backup-funktion es fertig habe ich
einige vorne und auch einige im
hintergrund und die partie sind auch
immer gefragt was das heißt jetzt kann
ich alles vorbereiten den grill haben
wir eben schon angemacht habe ich jetzt
noch ein paar grüne sprecher des aski
die nicht schafft wird und die schlitze
von allen die kommen gleich mit auf den
grill
wer mutig ist kann gerne auf die
scharfen nehmen aber das kann einfach
sein dass die wege verkauft sind
und die findet man zum beispiel in
türkischen supermärkten ganz gut
bisher sind jetzt die paprika und wenn
jetzt die schafe möchte packen alle
gemessen und es ist absehbar zufließen
dies ist zwar nicht aber ihm nicht
schaden
jetzt mache ich noch ganz typisch
türkisch eine joghurt soße das so und
ganz typisch berliner fällig dafür nehme
ich jetzt einen 10% joghurt der ist
nämlich richtig schön cremig und murat
hat sich so eine soße gewünscht wie beim
weltcup in stuttgart münster dönerladen
dort und da hat man auch schon richtig
feste so sind da nehme ich jetzt einfach
etwa ein halbes kilo und wird den
joghurt nur noch mit salz pfeffer und
getrocknet am ende wollte ursprünglich
noch blau mit rein geben und dann
eingefangen hat ja was wird dort mit
also brauche ich gar keinen knoblauch
salz und pfeffer reicht auf jeden fall
und minze und dann wird alles nur noch
verrückt
[Musik]
er ist auch bereit und habe jetzt noch
ein paar andere zutaten ich habe bereits
rote zwiebeln in ringe geschnitten habe
ich noch tomatenmark zum bestreiten der
brötchen und ich werde wahrscheinlich
den city noch mit käse überbacken monat
hat sich katies gewünscht das schmeckt
so in etwa wie gouda ich nehme
wahrscheinlich den wirklichen tour um
käse und dann geh jetzt noch draußen was
ich ja auch noch habe ich dann bald für
murat der macht gerne scharf und da
kümmert draußen auch die wölfe gleich
zusammensetzen
es ist auch wahr pünktlich zu essen und
jetzt kann gegrillt werden
ich lege jetzt zuerst einmal die partie
drauf direkt auf die heiße glut und die
kann ich dann wirklich gut drehen sobald
sich unten eine kruste gebildet hat es
dauerte etwas vier bis fünf minuten und
außen rum lag ich jetzt noch die paprika
ich brauche nicht viel hitze aber wer
trotzdem schön weg
[Musik]
und wer möchte kann später auch noch die
bagger bald einmal solche schreiben und
auch ganz kurz auf den grill legen
[Musik]
jetzt kann serviert werden
die berger brand habe ich jetzt auch ein
bisschen knusprig gebraten und lieber
murat stelle dir jetzt den ersten burger
zusammen kämpft sagte enders
die schau dich gerade an was wort
aufgefallen ich habe noch nie so
wunderschöne bürger gesehen und
natürlich deine augen auf stehen aber
die bürger
ich glaub schon geträumt einwickeln
formaten hat würde zb auch sambal olek
ihn genauer zeigen das werden wir sehen
wie ich meine zeit kommt aber er kaufte
es immer auf vorrat
ja es macht jetzt auch ein land das
jetzt wirklich alle typischen sachen
drin was man kennt
genau jetzt haben peter knoch kascha
noch drauf
das besondere ist dass der nicht zu arg
wird sich weil der wirt es ist alles
viel zu abwürfen dann die joghurt torte
stock nicht so viel schlucken
eine paprika genau da kann man auch
schafe nehmen ob ich mag mir die mögen
ich schneide ich jetzt einmal durch und
zwiebel genau die roten raben sind
einfach viel aromatischer dann habe ich
noch nicht ganz gesichert unterschied zu
werke und meinem normalen bürgern beim
normalen bürger trinken natürlich ein
softgetränk hast du ne cola und fanta
oder wasser limonade und bürger muss man
gibt einen stopp ein link links schießen
für meinen instagram account ok super
perfekt und den lassen wir unsere
schmecken abrantes mal einfach fragen zu
betreiben das ist der probleme und ich
werde natürlich gleich noch die
restlichen vorbereitungen sind bürger
die einfach so rein war erst mal
verlängert
und während rath den genüsslich ist als
wir werden auch gleich essen
aber ich will natürlich auch noch die
restlichen 20 zu bereiten für die
baustelle
ich habe wahnsinn unglaublich wirklich
die leute hören aus finden und was gut
mit dem mischen hackfleisch und wir
haben super ich find das liga schon so
gut auskennt mit dem schwarz kümmern und
hab mich mal so gesehen würde mich jetzt
noch mal heiraten will die normale rate
ich glaube der heilige gral der wahnsinn
ich glaube es ist der heilige gral der
bürger also das hinkriegt der kann sich
wirklich wirklich spongebob schwammkopf
elisabeth ist wahnsinnig wird ein
bisschen weniger saison nehmen
du wolltest doch im frühjahr aber ich
finde es wirklich gab ist perfekt dank
weit ist der schweizer essen ich noch
den abschluss ihres rezept auch
nachmachen möchte den friedberger in den
ski mit brötchen dann schaut auf meinem
blog vorbei auffälliges lockte ihn das
wird nochmal alles und ich wünsche euch
jetzt schon mal ganz viel spaß dabei und
wünsche uns hier allen einen guten
appetit bis zur nächsten baustelle zu
baustelle zu famila und dann für unser
team und dann noch nicht für die
baustelle
[Musik]
ja
noch
[Musik]